My name is Mike and I'm
here to talk to you today
about interactive
graphics in R.
A little bit about me.
I code in R for a living
and I believe R can be fun.
What do I mean by fun?
I mean things like
including kittens
in ggplots,
runnibng destructive
physics simulations,
and currently I'm experimenting
with voxel rendering.
There is fun to be had in R.
And today I'd like to share
with you such a discovery.
And that is with
careful use of base R,
interactive
graphics are possible
and this opens the way
for new visualizations.
And when I say new
visualizations,
I'm going to use
it to play games.
My interactive graphics
started with the game Wordle.
This has an intuitive
interface with animations
and a great user experience.
And so I created a
clone of this in R to play.
This was a text-based interface
which feels a bit clunky.
It does not have the feel or the
fluidity of the official game.
And I realized,
R gives easy access to
text interfaces, like Zork
on the left.
But I want to play actual video
games with sound and color
and graphics and
actual interaction,
like Pacman on the right.
So I set myself a moonshot goal.
I knew where I wanted
to go, but I didn't know
how I was going to get there.
And my moonshot was this.
I will commit myself
to achieving the goal,
before this year is out,
of writing and playing
a video game in R.
But this then
raises the question,
what extra things do I need to know
in R in order to get a game running?
And I needed to be
sure of three things.
I'm going to discuss
this with you today,
and that is a fast
graphics device
for rendering to, a fast way of
drawing to this graphics device
to render the game, and mouse
and keyboard interaction
so we can actually
play the game.
A fast graphics device is
essential if I actually
want to play games.
I need the graphics to respond
at least 30 frames per second.
If not, then the games
will never run smoothly.
When I say graphics device, I'm
referring to the area or window
where the plots are displayed
in R, like the plot
window in RStudio.
On the Mac,
there are a few other
graphics devices
that are the quartz
and the X11 device
and I needed to compare them
to find out what their speed
and response times were.
I wrote a very simple
benchmark to test
how fast a graphics
device would respond
to a simple plotting command.
And I was pleasantly surprised
that the graphics devices can
respond at 30 times per second.
In this plot, we see the
RStudio and the quartz device
both reaching 30 frames per
second, with the quartz device
about twice as fast
as the RStudio device.
What was really
surprising was to see
that the X11 device can respond
to commands at over 500 times
per second.
So yes, R does have a
fast graphics device. We're
over the first hurdle.
All graphics devices
can respond fast enough
and some graphics devices
are faster than others.
On the Mac, I'm going
to choose to use
the X11 device because
it is ridiculously fast.
Now that I'm confident that
the graphics device can respond
quickly, I need a fast way
of drawing to that graphics
device.
My focus is on
pixel-based games,
so blocky pixels and
polygons and character
sprites moving around,
like the game of Pac-Man.
A character sprite like
this cartoon dinosaur
is just a collection
of colored squares
and this can be
drawn very quickly
using just a base R graphics
command, grid rect.
If I draw this, clear the
screen, and draw it again
over and over, I can
get some animation.
To ensure this drawing
system can scale,
I'm going to use a common
animation technique known
as double buffering.
In double buffering,
there's one buffer for
drawing and one buffer
for rendering to the screen.
And I'm going to
implement it in R like this.
I'm going to create a buffer
in R, and then for every frame,
draw the game into the buffer.
And when that buffer is
ready, copy that buffer
into the graphics device.
For the drawing buffer.
I first considered
a standard R matrix.
This seems like a
pretty good match
for representing rectangular
array of pixels on the screen.
But I ran into some challenges
that actually slowed things
down, and that is
the data ordering
and the color representation
within a matrix.
In a matrix,
the data ordering is such
that sequential values define
a column. In a graphics device,
it wants sequential values
to define a row of pixels.
So there is a mismatch between
the data representation.
There is also a mismatch in the
color representation. In an R
matrix,
you would represent
color as a string,
but a graphics device actually
wants four numeric values
for the 4 bytes of red, green,
blue, and alpha color channels.
So the matrix data
layout does not
match the graphics
device, which means
if I was to render a matrix
to the graphics device,
then every single
time it actually
has to do an internal
data conversion
and this is going
to slow things down.
There is actually a second
rectangular data structure
in R that is more compatible
with graphics devices.
And that is the native raster.
The native raster is a built
in data structure in R,
but it is rarely used.
It's difficult to
manipulate from R,
but it is highly compatible
with graphics devices.
This table illustrates
that the native raster
object and the
graphics device have
the same data ordering and
the same color representation.
This means that the
native raster objects
will be very fast to copy
to the graphics device
as no conversion
will need to be done.
So my specific double
buffered rendering technique
looks like this.
I will create a native
raster buffer in R
then for every frame, draw
the game into that buffer
and then when it's ready, copy
that buffer to the graphics
device just with the
grid raster command.
This is a really powerful
and scalable technique.
It allows to R render multiple
sprites very quickly.
As a demonstration that this
double buffering technique
works,
this is a live capture of
three animated dinosaurs.
This is great, but three
objects aren't going
to make an interesting game.
And as I said, this
method scales and it
scales to 100 dinosaurs.
1,000 dinosaurs.
And the limit
I could reach before
the drawing speed
dropped below the magic
30 frames per second
was 5,000 dinosaurs.
And I was really
happy with this.
R has a fast way of drawing.
If I use the double buffering
technique using a native raster
as the drawing buffer
and then copy that buffer
to the graphics device
when it's ready.
The final piece of the
puzzle is interactivity,
an essential element of any game
that you actually want to play.
A standard way you
currently might get feedback
from the user is to request
text using the read line command
as shown here.
When calling readline,
R cannot do anything else.
It must have the
user input before it
proceeds to the next line.
In a similar manner,
you can get the mouse
position using grid locator.
But again, while waiting
for the user input,
R cannot do anything else.
So using this style
of interaction
would not work for video games.
Imagine a game of
Pacman where the game
stopped every time you needed
to control the main character.
It's not going to be an
interesting game or very fun.
We have to change our
programming approach
and make use of the event-driven
capabilities of our graphics
devices. In event
driven interaction,
we ask the system to monitor
for events, and when they occur,
we ask them to run a
particular function.
For those of you
familiar with Shiny,
it is based on an
event-driven framework.
If you had a button
on your web page,
you would not write a for loop
to check whether the button has
been clicked.
You would ask the system,
in this case Shiny,
that when the button is
clicked, please run my function.
And that's what the observe
event handler is in Shiny.
Like Shiny, R graphics
devices support
event-driven interaction.
So we don't need to monitor,
has the mouse moved or has
the keyboard been pressed?
We can ask the graphics
device to monitor for us.
And when that event occurs,
run a particular function.
This is all handled by the
grDevices package in the set
graphics event handlers function
where you can tie functions
to particular events.
The events that
you can watch for.
Has the mouse moved?
And you'll get back
the coordinates of the mouse.
You can monitor for the
mouse button being pressed,
in which case, you will
get back the button number.
You can ask for the keyboard
to be monitored, in which case
you'll get which key
has been pressed.
There is one extra
event to be monitored,
and that is the idle event, when
no other events are happening.
Consider the idle event
to be like the heartbeat
of an application. When the
user is doing something,
yes, we handle that input
and change our values,
but if the user is
not doing anything,
then we run our idle
function, our heartbeat.
This means that an application
skeleton might look something
like this.
When the mouse moves,
lets update the position of
the character on the screen.
When the keyboard
is pressed, lets
run a function that will check
whether the user wants to quit.
And when the user
is otherwise idle,
render the next frame
in the animation.
As proof that this event
driven interactivity works,
I wrote a drum machine
in R. A drum machine
is just an electronic
instrument that
plays drums. In this
drum machine interface,
each row represents
an instrument,
and each button means
to play that instrument
at a certain moment in time.
The events that I've
tied to this application
are that when the mouse
button is pressed,
we toggle the button
underneath the mouse
and when the user
is idle, we just
continue to play the next
beat in the sequence.
This is a short 20 second clip
showing the first song I ever
composed in our.
This was a lot of fun
to program and great fun
to experiment with and
compose my own songs.
And it shows that event
driven interaction
does work for what
I want for games.
I can simultaneously render
graphics and play sounds
while reacting to user input.
I now have all the key elements
that I need to play a game.
The only thing left is to
actually write the game itself.
And I'm not going to
write a game from scratch.
I'm actually going
to port an existing
game called Another World.
Another World is an
action adventure side
scrolling platformer released
in 1991 for many platforms.
It has a novel for its time
virtual machine architecture,
which makes it easy to
port to new systems.
It is, in effect,
just a polygon engine.
Rather than storing
bitmaps for scenes,
it just records a
description of how to render
that scene using polygons.
In this 20 second clip,
it is rendering the
first scene in the game.
And the next scene is
rendering a later scene
in the game where the main
character is having a drink.
So that's how an
individual frame
is rendered. For the actual
gameplay of Another World,
I created an R implementation
of the virtual machine.
This was based upon the
JavaScript and the C versions,
which were originally based upon
the assembly versions for MSDOS
and the Amiga.
The event driven game
loop is quite simple.
And I asked the graphics device
when the mouse or keyboard
are used,
it calls a function to
update the variables
in my virtual machine, and when
the user is otherwise idle,
it just executes the
next instruction.
Maybe to draw a polygon
or play a sound.
Which means
I can show you the
demo of the game.
This is a capture running live
in R to preview what's coming,
what you're going to see.
It is the typical
life of a scientist.
You arrive at work
in your Ferrari,
you drink at your desk,
and then your experiment
gets hit by lightning.
With that strike
of lightning, you
are transported
to another world.
Later in the game,
you are captured.
And you're stuck inside a jail.
This 10 second demo illustrates
keyboard interaction.
By using the left
and right arrow keys,
I am going to rock
the jail and escape.
What's up?
I don't know.
That jail escape
ends quite abruptly
because I have not
yet completed my goal.
There are still bugs
to fix and a package
to release before
I can claim that I
have a playable game in R.
What's next?
Hopefully today with
this presentation,
I've managed to demonstrate that
yes, with careful use of base R,
our interactive
graphics are possible,
and this opens the way to play
games and new visualizations.
I have released packages
to document this work.
And I encourage you to try them.
If you want to manipulate
native raster images from R,
I've released the nara package.
I've released a
friendlier wrapper
around the event callbacks
and the graphics devices.
This hopefully makes it a little
bit easier to use for games.
I know that Matt Dray
has used it already
for his retro dungeon
crawler, where
we can see his blue
character being
chased by the yellow monster.
If you want to see an example
of a complex event driven
application, I have released
the drum machine as a package.
And I hope soon to release
the Another World package
so that everyone
can play this game.
R has the capability to write
and run interactive graphics
and games, and I'm
fascinated to see
what the R community can create.
Game on.
Thank you.